no I'm brown I am the creator
and executor of this ecological park
observing a movement in nature that
there is a branch that lowers a sky that
flies and consequently the idea arises
maybe that movement I say I could also
make a  I play and after the time when the
military is set
I can work an hour a
whole day or a whole month of piano
the idea grows up when it is
finished 2000 I look at the question how nice
what I find I have done well since 40
to the 50 games there are of
course the smallest ones to the older ones all by
manual force there are no mechanisms
if you want to play here you have to push and
sweat
otherwise the game moves it this is
the important thing is the beauty of this
park for parents to make  see the children
how to play they
go up that not but in their hearts I am
convinced that they will return children too
and it's nice to see seconds
when I walk in the middle of my park here
especially when in the evening towards the
sunset I feel  only then do I look at myself
my heart widens for having created
from nothing into something that will then be
in time